guys who switch one through five it's
not a lot of us me Draymond Giannis well
you did you were like I should have won
the defensive player of the year the
last two years you said that I believe
that yeah yeah 100 I feel like you
should have won over Rudy and Marcus
it has to translate and I feel like Rudy
in the playoffs didn't translate
it's like the bubble so I'm very happy
that we made it happen I was going to
start this interview with something
completely different but now that I see
the do-rag we gotta dive into uh
the barber habits of bam marabayo
it has to be one person
how do you find them uh well I've had my
same Barber since what my rookie year
uh because going from Kentucky to Miami
I've decided to get a new Barber and
Juwan Howard actually recommended his
Barber
uh so ever since then I like the way he
cut my hair and I never switched up
so now it's more particular like now
obviously I got my money now so uh
so now I can I can fly him patients if I
really need them and
so yeah the Dewey is kind of I'm looking
a little rough today yeah but we can
have it fixed yeah we got it fixed so
Barbara flies out to you to cut your
hair
and you mentioned okay if I will put
these in advance because I know this is
when I need my hair done what are the
cities that you say okay the cut has to
be exactly what I need it to be
I would say
going on the west coast so obviously the
LA's uh
Brooklyn
New York
um
with some more cities
it's so funny because normally people
would say Miami but you're like I'm
always there yeah I'm always there yeah
uh
uh that's really it
yeah oh and when I go home to Charlotte
of course it has to be all right I'm
like fascinated by this because I wish I
could just fly somebody out to do my
hair once a week whenever I was going
that is not how it goes that's why on
Wednesday I'm going back to the locks
because getting your hair done is just a
whole it's a whole shebang but you do
have that power you just don't use it
but I don't do it because it's a it's a
different money you know what I'm saying
Fair yeah it's like now you're like I'm
flying them out I'm figuring it out
you're a two-time All-Star you can you
can do those kind of things speaking of
you know we have to dive into uh the
All-Star game it's been a lot of
opinions about if it was fun if it
wasn't what can change what we like what
was your opinion of the All-Star game uh
LeBron say glorified pickup
uh
uh and I mean that's that's what it was
what was it my my first All-Star
in Chicago
I think when they first introduced the
new rules
that's when I thought it got more
competitive yeah uh
but this year it was more like
it was it was just like we were just
getting cardio like cardio today there
was no defense in sight there was
nothing no okay so I'm with you I
totally understand why players feel this
way you're going out there you're just
getting up shots at the show I
understand but with that being said how
can it be fixed because it's the players
that are on the court
making the game
how can it be fixed uh I mean obviously
the easy answer is
dudes just got to play harder
I mean that's the easy answer but
uh I mean now you have guys that are
[Music]
um
they're like the franchise guy
and it the franchise guy wasn't what it
was back then
like a franchise got a franchise guy now
was like 200 million dollars worth
uh
uh so I feel like a lot of teams want to
protect their
100 million dollar 200 million dollar
asset yeah uh so I feel like that's the
the line that makes it difficult to be
serious in an All-Star game because it's
like we need you for the season but we
want you to enjoy like your Accolade
like that you deserve
um so yeah it's a it's a thin line yeah
you know and you're right when you talk
about Chicago when they added that Elon
mending obviously played to the Target
score plus 24. that does add an
intensity and competitiveness to it
because you have to do it in this
quarter I just wonder if there is a way
to have some sort of Target in every
quarter and it's about winning quarters
you know that can maybe
add something to it
I mean
technically we do have that because it's
a Target score at the end
yeah but then you only really play
because you know you have to win in the
end but like what if you have to win
every quarter do you get what I'm saying
so
how would you do the substitutions like
would you no you would sub out the same
way but it's like okay first quarter
it's the first like team to get to this
score to 50. yes like that and so then
you are having to work hard because
every quarter does matter as opposed to
you just get the plus 24 and the fourth
I don't know how it would work I need to
flesh it out a little more but if that's
what we like about the fourth quarter
right now what if we just kind of add it
to all the quarters
I'm not against it yeah we should start
to campaign
you're like no I don't like it that much
Jamal Crawford and I also think that on
Saturday nights there should be a
one-on-one competition that is added
two divisions six four and under six
five and up you challenge do you think
that guys would really decide to okay
I'm gonna put my pride on the line here
yeah really oh I'm excited I think guys
will get
more excited about one-on-one than they
would in like the actual All-Star game
yeah honestly because
that's when guys feel like they're the
freeze when they when they have it's
just one-on-one there's nobody else
around us it's just
me and you in a basketball and uh
it's kind of like pick up but
it's different when you know somebody
else is getting scored on in the
All-Star game it's a lot different when
you go into like five
and is you versus him yeah but it would
be so fire what matchup would you like
to see
matchup uh
uh
[Music]
all the time or just right now current
yeah current
I would say
JT and Jalen Brown we kind of got a
taste of that that's what I'm saying
yeah and those are some of the best
moments of the All-Star game but that
would be nice who would you challenge if
you got called up to do the one I wanted
All-Star Saturday uh
um
oh no at that point I feel like they
should just do a pull
and just take whoever just pick from a
hat yeah as you versus you and then you
start the game same way we did it with
the uh
the All-Star Game you pick your team
they just pick out a hat and see who go
to one-on-one first so you're saying if
this competition got added you'd be all
in you would do one-on-one
yeah okay I like that
[Music]
yeah like uh we have it on tape you guys
you add this Pam is signing up to do it
I think it really would add something
nice to it I enjoy all-star weekend but
I understand why there's so many other
things that happen that make players
feel tired sending meter requests like
you're having to do a lot so they are
gonna have to spice it up some way and I
think this could be a a fun way it won't
be next year yeah it was on it was on
is there an All-Star because obviously
you all spend so much time together is
there an All-Star that you walked away
from that weekend feeling like you knew
more about you just learned more about
them learn more about them uh
hmm
not
specifically a player but uh
the Boston Celtics head coach
oh okay uh so the guy I do meditation
with I started doing it this year and
it's helped me uh just for clarity wise
he is best friends with the
Celtics head coach
uh so he just walked up to me and said
man tell me tell me something like about
you just I just want to get to know you
like since it was all-star weekend we're
here
uh I was like yeah man I'm starting to
meditate and it just seemed like that
was just a highlight of our conversation
and it's funny because they've been cool
for like 12 years or in some change and
I've known Russ since
probably my second year in the league
uh but I never took meditation serious
until now and Russ is who is doing
leading meditation yes
uh
uh it was just it just comes full circle
because like I never would have thought
he would have said that like nah Russ is
my best friend and I was like kind of
like
really yeah he was like yeah man we've
been best friends since I think he was
like a college head coach
um
so yeah I wouldn't say a player it was
definitely the head coach though
like that why did you start
[Music]
Ed just because you know in the
basketball world today it's a lot of
it's a lot of it's a lot of bad energy
pointed towards you in certain certain
days certain games uh certain
performances
and it's one of those things where like
I never
wanted to keep trying to chase like a
high
uh
I wanted to be more at peace
um and just not go with the flow but
just have a a consistent
uh consistent Feeling by myself
and I think meditation going into the
game because you know it'd be some games
I'd be super hyped for so like my
anxiety be up like game be corn and I
feel like I'll get in my head
uh and meditation kind of like really
calmed that down and gave me like a
sense of clarity and uh now I it's like
it's kind of like I'm going to play
pickup like I'm going to hoop now uh
back then it was more so like this is my
job I got to perform
uh this then the third like it just gave
me anxiety with it and now it's more
level-headed and more consistent so you
meditate right before the game
so when we say right before right before
I say
if it's 90 on the clock I meditate
around
that's great yeah give me like a
five six minutes meditation uh get my
ankle tape it's time to go so what did
you have to release about yourself
to get this clarity
I had to believe that it'll work that
was the first thing for me uh because
before I used to look at meditation I
would try it on my own but I'd be like
man this isn't helping me
uh and you know getting with Russ he was
like nah you actually gotta like believe
in it like
and once I started believing in it
they'd be like
I gave it like the first three games I
really started like getting in a
rotation with it I could feel my mind
just like
go to like a a it was steady
it wasn't any like I'm thinking about
this I'm thinking about this this like
if I missed a shot uh turnover it was
more so like no I just play the game
uh so now it's kind of kind of mellowed
out my uh my anxiety
I mean it sounds like this is something
that is very positively changed your
life uh the ways that you're talking
about it what did meditating teach you
about bam man uh
I'll be having a lot of stuff on my mind
at one time trying to focus on one thing
but my mind be I'll think about this
I'll think about that and then it'd be
and then I'll get distracted
so it's like all right I forget about
this they move on uh
but it just helped me like really start
to like zero in on one thing instead of
all right you know I'll be in the middle
of the game and it's like ah I gotta get
my hair cut tomorrow uh I gotta I got an
event in two days
um
we down we down two and I gotta make
these free throws because it's in the
fourth uh just my mind be everywhere
instead of focusing on the main thing
and I feel like meditation has can't
brought me to like a steady
steady place where like now I can zero
in and you feel like you have that
Clarity and that peace that you you were
talking about yeah so now it's not I
don't try to like
ride my highs with like enjoy to try to
keep it this way like it's kind of like
expect to expect that like I know the
season is going to be like this
so it's just for me mentally just try to
be as even killed as possible
I mean it's hard just generally in life
not just in basketball to not want to
chase the high of things for sure and so
that I think is probably the biggest
hurdle that anyone would have to jump
over but you have made that switch when
in your career were you chasing that
high uh
after my first All-Star
um and what was the high for you it was
just having
first it was my first All-Star so it was
kind of like
you know you get considered the top 24
in the league it's like
you feel like you're one of them uh so
I just tried to like just chase that
like if I be an All-Star like every year
like I like I'm I'm devoting myself to
the end
it became instead of trying to chase
that
uh
just more so like
we're about the game like you know after
that it was kind of like I just bought
in my mind like nah I need to be
All-Star reviewer to like solidify like
a good a good year for me
um
and I guess when I started meditating it
kind of
it's kind of like dog you ain't got to
chase that like just
your game will speak for itself yeah and
it has to your credit I'm sure you
probably felt like a bit of a maybe a
flip switched once you decided to shift
your focus to certain things
um and I am not trying to get you back
onto the chasing of the high but I do
want to talk about how crazy it has been
watching your career but also this past
All-Star because I was just talking to
my friend about this when you all were
sitting in that locker room right in
Utah I think 19 of you were 30 or under
19 of you were 30 or under 12 of you 26
are under
were you kind of looking around thinking
okay is this starting to be those
moments where this becomes our league
yeah you can uh
I can definitely understand I can
definitely see that yes uh sitting
around because now you see younger guys
um you know you got guys who obviously
LeBron Katie uh Kyrie you know they've
been through this they've been on that
path so
for us I do feel like it's starting to
it's starting to change uh this the
Torches are starting to be passed
and it's uh it's starting to be the end
of some eras uh
so yeah I feel like we're we're next in
line
so what is it like being on the court
and playing basketball during this kind
of tweener
moment
uh
life lessons
um obviously from the older guys who are
in All State game you can talk to them
and ask them about the multiple All-Star
games they've been in and how the game
was
then versus now and then you got the the
new guys like
Darren Fox who is his you know I've
known him since we were probably
12.
this past also was his first so like
seeing his opinions on it and then
versus listening to somebody like Kyrie
or or Braun uh and how different the
the attitudes are towards it
um give me an example
so like
for me my first one
I wouldn't say Starstruck but it was
kind of like
like it's it's only 24 of us here yeah
like it was kind of like
I would used to watch this on TV now I'm
in it and
you know as a first timer you don't know
what to do where to go uh you have all
these lists of
appearances meetings uh media practice
and I feel like your day is more so
involved with that then you know
realizing you got to play the game on
Sunday uh and I feel like guys like who
get older like they have done all the
media they've done all the practice they
know the routine All-Star uh
and they can kind of gear themselves up
for the game more uh I feel like that's
the the experiences I feel like is this
yeah difference just how they're taking
it in differently yes okay no that makes
total sense so when you think of the
older guys and just generally not
All-Star just the league in general
how will you know that that torch has
been passed
um
[Music]
when LeBron James retires
I feel like that's when the Torches
officially passed
explain uh I mean first of all he just
beat Korean
uh well he's been in this league 20
years now and Counting
and I feel like
if they ever debate best player in the
in the game until he leaves
you know what I mean like people can say
like we have this opinion we have this
opinion but somebody's gonna always be
like
LeBron James yeah yeah like until he
leaves I think that's when people are
going going to start being like nah this
one guy is the best player yeah uh
so yeah until he leaves I don't think
there'll really be like a
setting Stone answer yeah so that
changing of the guards in that new era
you feel like goes through whether
LeBron is playing whether he's not I
think that's very fair it's really
interesting too because you know when
you're in a moment you don't necessarily
realize that you're living in the moment
and I think that LeBron for a lot of
people once he passed cream it was like
oh no no this is what we're going to be
talking about and those like 50 years
LeBron is that person but you know this
is all cyclical and history repeats
itself continuously in this league so
when LeBron is done and we have these
other years who becomes the LeBron of
the NBA because it has to be someone
um
uh
uh I'll say next up uh
uh I think is Giannis
I like that answer and agree but Giannis
is one person that is somewhat of a
tweener like you can't really say he's
in like the young group but he's not in
the old group 100 but he's done so much
in his
in the span of his career absolutely
absolutely I feel like it gives him the
the say-so to say like he's he's the
best player yeah no I agree I think that
when it comes to like being the best
player when LeBron's done it totally as
Giannis but he's gonna have this kind of
he'll be in two eras at once in the best
way yeah yeah but what makes Giannis so
good for people that don't completely
understand uh
I mean he's seven foot first of all
right it's 7-1 uh
and I think the thing that really got
him on the scene was when he would just
take off from like the free throw line
or he'll get down to court in like three
dribbles and dunk it uh just very
2kish if that makes sense it looks very
unreal
uh and I feel like that's the thing that
put
Jordan over the top you know that's what
put Kobe in that in that
um bra is like they had this special
I'm not gonna say swag but it was like
this
special gift day only had uh that just
made them different from everybody else
and I feel like the fact that he can two
two-step through four people and dunk
the basketball is like
people think it's like boring now but
like that is really like different yeah
uh
so yeah and with the honest too you
almost like you feel it you feel it when
he steps on the court also I'm gonna
give you a chance clear this up viral
video Jana says winner winner chicken
dinner camera Zooms in on you
did you not think it was funny did you
not hear it what was the face I didn't
hear it
so that's what's funny I didn't hear it
uh
I'm sitting here talking to Dame
and obviously you watch it but as soon
as me and Dame start I stop having that
conversation I guess he says what do you
say he said winner winner chicken dinner
yeah I didn't know that yeah so uh
the next day I'm getting all these DMs
like dog like you're hilarious and I'm
like what are we talking about
and it was like just watch his face and
I was like
yeah that did look bad yeah cause you
went like
okay so it cleared up you think winner
winner chicken dinner is a funny thing
to say
just I think for him yes yes okay there
we go internet internet sleuths he
didn't even hear it okay I love it all
right let's turn our attention to you
you have said that you are the best
defender in the NBA Make Your Case
I mean
a guard one through five uh
you see it day in day out like legit one
through five
I switch everything uh
I mean yeah like there's what do you
need me to do on the defensive end
uh
I feel like that's the
that's the most I can give myself mm-hmm
but what else you need
is it frustrating for you when you
aren't a finalist is that something that
really bothers you
uh uh it did
not anymore uh
just because it was it was something I
was chasing uh
and
and it bothered me just because I was
chasing and I felt like people were
disrespecting me uh
because I felt like obviously nobody was
a better defender of me in the league
but
it it doesn't bother me anymore because
now like I said I play the game uh
you know I go out there I compete with
my teammates and I have complete Clarity
and uh Focus focused on the game yeah so
now it's something that like you want to
win but you don't think you're defined
by whether or not you went in it's not
something you're thinking about when you
step out there yeah yeah now I just
my gang gonna do the talking
so just going off of that what do you
think should be the things that we all
think about when we are you know placing
our votes for defensive player of the
year what is that criteria for you do
you think there should be any sort of
stipulations around the award
uh
uh obviously I feel like obviously
people are gonna say missed games which
is very fair which is fair uh I just
think though
I don't think stats
like you should you shouldn't only look
at stats when it comes to dpoi
because
a lot of times a guy might not have
60 blocks but they might have the number
one
they might have the number one defense
or they might protect the paint they
might be number one and protecting the
paint
uh
uh so for me I don't think it's
just
blocks steals
uh if you want to consider charges
uh it's more so like
how was the team when he's on the court
and they're playing defense versus when
like he's off
so I feel like those are need to be
in this situation rather than looking
like oh well he had five blocks a day
well he could have had five blocks but
also giving up yeah
60 points uh
I feel like that matters no I think
that's super fair and like when I had
Draymond on the show he said something
that I always think about which is we
should judge defense the same way that
we judge offense and what defensive
situation do you need this person to be
on the floor and he's like people get
too caught up in like what these numbers
are but the stats and the analytics and
all that was never meant to be looked at
solo and in a vacuum it's like you have
to just add that to things like the eye
test like all of that is a part of what
defense is but how do you think we get
away from that because it feels like it
is kind of taking over how people watch
the game
uh
uh I feel like just because when
obviously when everybody goes to to the
end of the game
or if they check the box score they're
looking at points and then they're like
oh this guy has five blocks uh he had
three steals
okay you know he's out dpoy
you know that's how the agenda starts
you know which is like nonsensical yeah
yes yeah exactly yeah but if people
actually like really watch the games
uh I feel like that's how they get more
of an understanding of
situations that our players are put in
like I feel like guys who switch one
through five it's not a lot of us me
Draymond Giannis
uh who else I'm gonna let you say your
list I don't want to interject my
opinion
no it's fine
uh well last year what Marcus tomorrow
on year before that Rudy won right yeah
but Rudy camp
[Music]
yeah you say Rudy no no well you did you
were like I should have won the
defensive player of the year the last
two years you said that
I believe that yeah 100 I feel like you
should have won over Rudy and Marcus
it has to translate and I feel like Rudy
in the playoffs didn't translate
uh
and Marcus Smart guys went through four
yeah like I got them all exactly uh
so that's the
that's the thing that I think I thought
was different
um between me and them
okay that's fair so then how do you make
that leap
this season just defensively I know it's
not a thing you're chasing but if you're
just working on being a better player
every day
how do you get people to think of you
when they think about dpoi and not a
market so you know a Rudy in that year
uh they gotta watch our games
that's the biggest thing and obviously
we're not one of them teams that always
give always play on TV
uh so we don't get National exposure as
much as other people
we are Miami
I I hear you but like are you serious I
hear you but you all also do we plan on
do you beat them not a lot okay I didn't
say we didn't plan yeah yeah we don't
play on TV Fair then more than most yeah
uh
uh so I feel like that is also another
layer
um
but
other than that I mean really people
just got to watch the games but I'm
saying tune in y'all
okay speaking of the Miami Heat uh you
got to create some [__] space for
Kevin Love
[Laughter]
is that on the agenda yes
yes going on
three or four years now uh
uh he was one of the people where like I
made my jump
um
was my second year I think it was my
second year at the end of my second year
he started noticing like I was becoming
obviously a better player and I wasn't
just
on the defensive side I was gaining more
more offensive game
and he wanted my jersey
and it was just crazy to me that like
obviously he's won and you know multiple
All-Stars uh
and let's not forget Minnesota Kevin
Love
exactly
so I thought it was dope they're like
dang like Kevin Love wants my jersey
yeah
and then from there I seen him in the
Olympics he was with us uh
for the start uh and obviously getting
to talk to him a little bit this and
that there
but now he's on the team yeah so good to
have him play some space for him what
creates a space for him why is Kevin
Love like that exact big for you
uh
uh IQ
and I feel like he's been around this
league he's a bit uh he's been in those
those situations where obviously they
were down what I said 3-1 3-1 come back
and win uh being a part of that that's
an experience
I feel like K-LOVE has you know those
experiences that
guys like myself and my teammates want
to be a part of which is win a
championship yeah
um so obviously he fits that mold for us
just he knows that experience and how to
get there
no I first off you should always ask and
you probably know this whenever you all
go somewhere you should ask Kevin which
wine y'all should get he always will
pick the exact perfect wine he like has
a wine he like you know he's a big wine
guy but just a tip for when you all your
team outings with uh okay with Kevin
always asking the why and he'll always
know I was reading a quote from Jimmy
actually talking about the Heat team and
some of the struggles and he just said
I'm tired of losing he's like we have to
get it fixed very quickly where are you
at mentally with the state of the team
right now
I mean I agree with him uh
nobody's like
nobody's comfortable with losing uh well
in our locker room nobody's comfortable
with losing so
you know when you go
two three games in a row four losses uh
it starts to wear on you
um
and obviously we're one of those
franchises like we we like wins yeah so
we want to win every game if possible
need be uh
and I feel like the struggles come from
we let a lot of games go that we should
have won
and we just let them slip uh
and that's the the up and down of the
Season you know like
we struggle making shots sometimes
sometimes shots go in uh so it's more so
I I agree with him yeah how much
pressure do you feel to right the ship
uh
I mean as
being one of the Cornerstone guys of the
organization you want to win so when
you're on a losing streak like it's
for me you know I just take it upon
myself to be like nah like we gotta
figure this out uh
and it's not only me like I try to bring
my teammates with me uh
so like if I'm performing like I'll try
to get all my teammates involved so we
can all get comfortable
and go out there and get us a win
as you've progressed in the league and
you understand more you get more
experience how do you personally deal
with losing
uh
uh man still keeps me up at night
because I it's like it's certain
segments of the game or certain plays in
the game that you know they just run
through your head all night uh
so now I can meditate uh I do a better
job of meditating
before I go to bed so then like I can
get a good night's sleep
all right what do you use to meditate is
it just rust do you use like any of the
apps what do you do so he got me an app
and it's called Vision Pursuit and it's
uh
it basically takes you step by step on
meditation uh
so what is it called it's called C
it separates your emotions you expect to
expect in the last is embrace
uh so it just teaches you step by step
how to deal with
certain stuff in your life what you're
going through uh
and at the end it makes you do like a
little Journal
uh to review like how you felt what you
went through
the experiences you had and how you use
the the technique to get through it
really
love that what you said what set
expectations Embrace and what was the
other one uh expect to expect it expect
the expected which tool do you find
yourself using the most expect to expect
it
okay how so uh I mean simple thing is
like going into the season knowing like
season's gonna be up and down yeah uh so
expecting that you know I feel like
you're more prepared for it so like if
y'all do have a like a shooting slump
you're not too sideways off of it or
like you go through a little rough patch
and you can't make shots like you're not
too sideways about it uh
or you come out the you come out the
gates hot and it's like nah I'm trying
to ride this the whole season uh it's
more so just being prepared for like if
you do
take a dip like it's you can get back on
your hot horse
okay so I have to say and I am not just
saying this
from when I like first met you to this
moment you do feel like just a lot more
Zen yeah yeah like do you do you feel
that yeah I'm like I'm talking like wow
yeah this is like we all need to be calm
and have this Clarity and this isn't
even just something that is happening in
the basketball court I'm saying you
specifically you just feel
a bit more at peace and I think more so
in tune with yourself is that fair to
say yeah yeah because more so uh
being self-aware because I know once I
get around you know cameras lights like
my anxiety go up like I know I'm like
all right like we it's about to be
Showtime yeah uh and that doesn't matter
like if it's in here and we're doing
this or it's stepping out in the court
like I don't think
anxiety picks what to really be like up
in Roar about like it's kind of like
certain situations you get in it just
kind of kind of Sparks yeah uh and I
feel like you know during meditation
I've done a great job of kind of
mellowing out and like not letting your
environment dictate the bam that we get
in that moment it's just letting bam be
ban in the environment adapt exactly
that no I think that's great I I really
mean it I think it's great that you are
really like being in tune and all the
things and I'll I'll get off the
meditation if I'm just genuinely curious
about it I gotta download the app uh
okay but back to the basketball court
when I say Boston Celtics
what emotion comes to mind
ah
I don't like the Boston Celtics
nah uh
and it's mainly because uh
obviously JT I've known JT since we were
12. so
obviously when we play each other it's a
dog fight like
I want to be like dog like I have more
wins than you
like that's that's how I am it's a
personal it's a personal
it's a personal battle right there like
no like I wanna at the end of our
careers be like well
when we played you this many times Well
we played each other like bam has more
wins including regular season playoffs
whatever you want to say I'm Top Dog
and that's what you're gunning for yep
so before and after those games what are
those texts like between you and Jason
uh
uh before a game
I don't text Jason
I don't I don't talk to Jason before
games uh but after games it's more so
it's more so love because we played the
game
puzzling off win lose a draw like
he's still one of my one of our one of
my great friends in the league so
it's all love at that after the buzzer
go off but
before that no I'm not talking to you
um no I'm not cool with you yeah you're
like we're not friends here no I was
reading an article where someone was
talking to you just about you know the
heat Celtics rivalry and you said some
people just don't get it they don't get
it
what don't people get about that rivalry
it's got so much history with it and I
feel like it started from
The Big Three uh
and you've seen those battles you've
seen
how ugly it get like you've seen when
Rey went from Boston to Miami how like
they kind of like
I'm not gonna say turned on them but
like that's how it was back in the day
like yeah you with them now like we
don't [__] with you
uh so I feel like it's still it's still
there because one obviously we still
have UD
yeah so UD went through
UD went through that he's like The
Godfather I feel like yes exactly
uh so like when he explains the stories
like of
to game six Broadhead like when he
explains the battles of the regular
season when he explains how they treated
Rey when he came to the heat like you
start to develop
like the
the energy for it and then also like
going in Boston is not
you know back in the day it wasn't
it wasn't all cute and copacetic for for
African Americans
uh
uh so you know obviously they add that
factor into it like when you walk in
what is it called the uh what TD Garden
no no no the uh leprechaun oh uh lucky
yeah they uh they really believe in that
like they like so
going in there and like
getting a win like with us is like
would you say that's like that's the
most personal gain
yeah
yeah that's the most personal game for
us so what does it bring out of you
specifically
because you tend to perform
[Laughter]
it's one of those things where
it's just it's the it's the environment
like you can't as soon as you step in
the arena and we're like it's it's
Boston versus Miami no matter what
decisions it is like
all right this might be a thought this
is gonna be a dog fight yeah you're hype
talking about it right now yeah like I
like my blood get going uh yeah cause I
I enjoy that game so much because
obviously like across from me is like
like I watched JT when he was 12. like
we were both 12 at the time like I
watched Jalen Brown me and me and Grant
Williams competed against each other in
in college uh me and who else was on
their team uh Robert Williams competed
against each other in college so like
it's a lot of like
we've crossed each other's paths before
so like yeah we know of each other or
know each other uh
and obviously I'm I like to talk my [__]
so like when we win like that's the
first thing JT here
and it's vice versa so
so like with those games it's like
nah you better bring your A game because
if I win I'm talking this [__] yeah are
you a big trash talker just generally
nah but that one yeah that one that one
that one's first yeah that one you gotta
get going yeah I mean it's super
interesting though because obviously
when you are looking at the conference
just you think okay you're gonna be
facing
the Celtics or the Bucks like come
playoffs when you look at the Eastern
Conference as a whole what do you see
man uh
it's a lot of
I would say up ups and downs in the East
it's like you've seen you've seen some
some teams go on
10 game winning streaks
but you've seen some lose seven in a row
some people will go man unexpected six
in a row
and they'll lose five in a row again
yeah uh so I it's kind of the the up and
down
battles of the season
and
it is I would say it's up for grabs
uh if it you can figure out how to be
the most consistent
Up Programs you can figure out how to be
the most consistent who do you feel in
the East is the most consistent right
now right now uh because they're on
well I'll say Boston in the books yeah
Boston in the books yeah
when I interviewed dejounte Murray he
was telling me about a conversation he
had with LeBron about the East and he
agreed with this he said LeBron told him
the East was more physical than the West
do you agree with that and your
experience have you seen that
I don't play in the west often so I
can't I can't speak for that uh do I
feel the East is physical yes I do uh
do I know if it's more physical I don't
know I haven't uh
I haven't been on the west coast enough
yeah but you like it's physical in the
East when I'm playing for sure I don't
know if you remember this but you and I
were talking about the bubble and you
said that there was one time you cried
in the bubble and it was when you all
lost in the finals because you just felt
like something was taken from you
when you'll think about winning a
championship is that one of the moments
that you remember in your head yeah
because it's uh
the one thing about the Championships
like yeah like you remember like the
glory like the fun champagne all that
but
it was more so like the the Journey of
it
uh
like for example like the Olympics for
us like everybody know we won it was
great when we won celebrated but
going through the fire
of getting critiques everybody's saying
what's wrong with USA uh
people saying like we should have the
USA ripped off our jerseys off our chest
uh it was kind of like
the whole country was like what are
y'all doing
and it was like going through that like
people might think well it's just my one
opinion
but like your opinion is with somebody
else's opinion added to somebody else's
opinion uh
so it's kind of like more so
people wanted to see us fail
just so they could be right
and I felt you know that Journey was
like damn like
it was cool that we won but like do
y'all remember how they how bad they was
talking about us like
that and that's like the conversations
like you can always have with like I
could always have that with a dream on
um like I can walk up and be like dog
you remember when they was like really
[__] talking Us in the Olympics and it's
like yeah we got to go metal though uh
and I feel like that's what you know you
you remember like the grind of it the
the ups and downs of it so yeah
I won a championship I'm gonna go back
to when I was like damn like I really
cried in the bubble because
we were there for what a hundred and a
long time exactly yes so you're there
for a hundred and something days and
then you get down to the final two and
then obviously everybody else leaves so
it's just like
you walk past your opponent every day on
the way to breakfast
like you take different buses but y'all
see each other from across the parking
lot yeah
how big was it for you
getting that
um
one because I had put we put the Boston
Celtics out yes
um
but two is just
it was surreal because like I watched so
many greats playing the finals
and getting that opportunity to step on
the court and see like the finals logo
and like
when you go home there is no other game
on like you were the in the game
uh so I feel like that is like what you
remember about it most like that's the
that's the surreal taste of it I also
think too when you talk about you know
that Journey to the finals what it takes
to get there
in my experience when people make it to
the NBA and they've taken that Journey
their opinion of the way that we talk
about things like green culture
completely changes
did that happen for you yeah how so yeah
I mean
foreign
16 wins
that's that's what you need to get to a
championship and it sounds so easy
like when you think about it he was like
man all you need is 16 wins
like you'd be like that's it yeah 16
wins
and I'm able to lose
every series possibly three yeah you
just got to get four wins each year it
sounds easy until you go through that
gauntlet
and that's after the regular season so
now it's like
you really gotta be like all right
it's all hands on deck at this point
like there is no like you know I need a
break and you know I can't go as hard
like nah you need 16 wins uh
and preparing yourself for that is like
it's like it feels like it's like a job
at that point yeah because now with zero
focusing like there is no
I'm gonna go to dinner I'm gonna hang
out with my friends like there's no
nothing because I know you're trying to
win it all you're trying to win it all
like everything gets you zeroed out
I just feel like you know it would be
hard and we talk about chasing the high
right
it's like that would be what I would
always be thinking about I have to get
back to feeling that exact thing but
that would weigh on a person
pretty heavily I assume
uh
yeah because you start
you start thinking about like
you know what it felt like to be like
when I ran on the court and I seen the
final symbols like that like
we got we got 12 more wins like
what it felt like to you know warm up
and be the last two teams standing
that's like at that point you're four
wins away from your goal
but it's like the hardest four wins ever
um like it's one thing like I always say
this since I've been in the playoffs now
the hardest thing to get is the fourth
one
I feel like that is the hardest one to
get the fourth win is the hardest one
because it's like that's when the other
team is like
it's it's win or go home like there is
no like we got a second chance at this
point
to that fourth win that's the one that
you really have to get past yes yeah I
love it I mean obviously I'll be rooting
for you as you continue your career many
many playoffs hopefully many finals
um I do have one last kind of section
for you I want to talk about uh because
I was reading a really interesting
article that you did for anscape and it
was just about your name and how you
have kind of come into understanding
your roots and your heritage and all of
this what is your full name
is that about Idris bio say it again
slowly so everyone can hear Idris femi
adebayo and in this article it is kind
of discussing the journey that you have
taken
to understand I guess yourself
what have been some of the stops on that
Journey for you
uh
uh I mean first I had to really because
it started obviously like
um single parent
so is always my mom so I never really
had a connection with my father and he
was Nigerian
so for a long time in my life like
living with my mom
I didn't want to represent somebody that
wasn't in my life so like for a period
of time it was like
I used to try and hide being Nigerian
obviously it's harder to do because my
last name but
like it was kind of like nah like
I didn't really buy into it like I
wasn't like it was kind of like it took
me a minute to be like
all right this is really a part of you
my guy like you gotta you gotta get in
touch with it yeah and it took me until
like I was probably like 15 16 to really
be like
all right my my last name's like uh I'm
Nigerian like I'm starting to really
unders not understand it but like I'm
starting to lighten up on like
you know people ask me if I'm Nigerian
or not I'm starting to
more so now open up and be like yes yeah
instead of being like nah like
you know I don't really claim it because
like my parent was one of my parents
wasn't in my life that held that
Nigerian
um
so for me now it's more so like
now I want to go to Nigeria yeah now I
want to see the motherland now I want to
be a part of it because now
and this is what social media has helped
us like
now you see the great things that like
Africa has to offer for us so many great
things yeah so when I was younger
I I completely
cut it off like I didn't want to have
anything to do with it and
my mom blessings to her because she's my
pride and joy uh shout out to Mom yeah
she was one of the people that was
really like not like you really need to
like
start to understand like what your name
means and like where you come from and
you know this is
these are your ancestors and like how
you need to get in touch with the
motherland
um
so yeah she was always on me about it
and I should always be like nah I'm good
like I don't I'm good like I don't
I don't need that right now like
he's not a part of our life why do we
need to worry about it
and that was kind of how I thought about
it as a youngster so now me being older
more so is like I need to see
the other side of the world now at this
point yeah and you're like I'm proud
yeah so now it's like I'm proud to be
like Nam Nigerian descent I love that uh
so it's it's a sense of Pride now
because now you see how hard some people
work to like make a name for themselves
uh and they want their name to hold
weight
so now you know more so instead of a 15
year old kid really running from
like
what he
what he has
uh now more so like I'm open to it uh
I'm open to learning about my last name
I'll open the going to Nigeria and
seeing the land
so for me it's just it's just gonna add
another
another layer of my life that I can
expand on and uh be comfortable talking
about for sure because name and identity
are just so personal to people that I I
can understand why you'd kind of have
this push and pull of okay what does
this mean to me based on my relation to
him and how were you kind of able to
Grapple with the relationship with your
dad
and also wanting to learn
uh I had to
I had to understand that
what
he had going on and what his situation
was
it couldn't affect me
uh
uh so even though he wasn't in my life I
couldn't
now I think about it it was dumb for me
to be like all right that [__] like [__]
him [__] the name like
it used to be times I used to tell my
mom like can I get it changed like
could I have your last name like that's
how I used to talk to my mom and she'd
be like no yeah
thank God she didn't listen to me as a
15 year old uh
but now it's more so like
I had to
forgive and kind of
you know just
think about the brighter days about it
like all right you want in my life
I let it go
that don't mean you gotta come back
but it's more so like I just let that
that that that that inner beef that I
had I just let it go um
I'm sure that lends to the cell phone
yeah and the clarity and the peace and
the meditation it all comes full circle
all right last question for you
what if
you weren't an NBA player what would you
be doing if I am I still This Tall yes
you're still you okay you just cannot
play in the NBA
um
when I was growing up I wanted to be
around Sports so I wanted to be a
physical therapist
what if it's not Sports adjacent
[Laughter]
um
got me there
uh
oh no
um
I will say you're giving me like
life coach at this stage
I mean it's like you could teach
meditation no I can't see something now
yeah I think you could no no no you just
like sports it's it's within me yeah uh
I don't know man
I'll probably try to take on acting or
something I probably want to be in a
movie okay actor bam I love it also I
need to say this because I had this
thought what like a few days ago when
Darren Emily went crazy
y'all were on the same team if I
remember correctly
I mean what what happened
that was a lot of Talent on one team uh
what happened yes what happened
I mean
you just gotta ask
you
it's hard for me to say it because I
don't want to sound like I'm hating
because I'm not hating that's one thing
I'm not say it what is it but
we gonna all say we feel like we got
cheated
okay explain Okay so
referee that ref the referee that left
our game one referee
Cal was like one and like nine
against with him rapping our game
so obviously we get in the game
four out of our five starters have two
fives in the first half so you know
college you still play half yeah so you
get your first two like it's kind of
like all right bro like we gotta sit you
into the second yeah
and
four of our five starters get files
and it's kind of
it it kind of goes from there uh we
fight back
dude is a crazy shot game over
uh
after that though I guess the referee
has like a a roofing business so like
our fans just like
calling his lines block these lines oh
no give him like one star on that one
star reviews like threatening them like
to the point like you had to get law
enforcement involved oh no because it
was that bad because like yeah
obviously with us we're gonna be like
all right we got cheated but uh they won
the game so what whatever
um
and yeah so you've been holding on to
that you're like this is how I feel
about this Kentucky team
because I feel like we would want well
hey you have another chance to win a
championship in a different League now
there it is I appreciate your time babe
I'm so happy we did this I feel like I
learned so much and I'm gonna pick up on
this meditation I think you might need
it I got you thank you so much you're
welcome
foreign
[Music]